Okay, square root was
intentionally simple here.
Let's try now giving a precondition for
sort, okay?
What do you think are the required
conditions in order for sort to execute?
>> I guess depending on how you
might want to write your function,
we should say something
about having an empty,
we need a non-empty set
of a vector of integers.
I guess you could have an empty set
of integers, or an empty vector and
still have integers, but you wouldn't
get anything meaningful back.
So it seems to kind of fall in the same
category with the negative number in our
square root function, maybe.
Does it matter?
>> Okay, so
Jared mentioned a couple things here.
One is he did say that
it was important in our particular
case to deal with integers.
And what we're going to do there
is we're going to say as far as
our preconditions and post-conditions
are concerned, we're not going to be
concerned with the data types of the
input arguments and the output results.
We're going to assume that
the signature took care of that.
And ultimately when
the program is turned into code
the type checker on the compiler is
going to do that kind of checking, okay?
So we're not going to include
in the precondition any
statements about the types of things,
okay?
And then the second thing
that Jared mentioned was,
there was an uncertainty about what to
do in the case of an empty vector, okay?
And he said if you give
in an empty vector,
you wouldn't get any
meaningful results back.
But I would come back and say, well,
isn't the sort of an empty
vector an empty vector?
>> It is.
>> Okay, so
it's a meaningful result there.
Now we could have a precondition that
said the length is greater than or
equal to one.
And we have a perfectly
good sort routine there.
But we can stretch it,
make it a little bit more general,
by saying that the sort of an empty
vector is an empty vector.
And of course, all of us are computer
scientists, and as such we
like to have general solutions that work
in as many cases as we can deal with.
So in this case we're going to go with
the fact that we're going to specify
something that will work on an empty
vector and produce an empty result.
So when you factor all those things in,
what's the precondition of sort?
>> Okay, so x must be a vector, and-
>> But
that the compiler's
going to take care of.
We're not worried about that.
>> Right, okay.
>> Okay?
What are the conditions
on x that must hold.
>> I don't know if there are any.
>> That's right.
And if we are not concerned about
the type checking parts of things,
then any input vector of integers
sort should be able to deal with.
So in this case there
is no precondition, or
we could also say
the precondition is true.
That is, the precondition always holds.